Harry and Megan's relationship with the
Royals has had huge twists and turns so
how do we get here here's your timeline
of the key events
Kensington Palace first announced Harry
and Megan's relationship in November
2016 but the confirmation came with a
Stern statement a line had been crossed
it read a speculation had made Meghan
Markle subject to a wave of abuse and
harassment
at the time there were reports Prince
William wasn't happy with Harry's
decision to speak out in response he
issued a statement giving the couple his
full support
but how much Royal support was there for
the new couple
several reports claim the Brothers Rift
began in 2016 when William expressed
concerns about the speed at which
Harry's relationship with Megan was
moving Robert Lacey the historical
consultant to the Netflix drama the
crown claimed William asked Diana's
brother Charles Spencer to speak to
Harry
Harry was reportedly furious at his
brother for this
by November 2017 he and Megan were
engaged congratulations from all of us
how are you both feeling Royal fiances
are not typically included in the
official Christmas activities but the
late Queen broke with tradition and
invited Meghan Markle to join the family
for Christmas at her Sandringham estate
according to the Royal reporter Katie
Nichol the invitation happened because
Prince Harry had complained his brother
wasn't doing enough to include Megan in
the royal family
[Music]
in October 2019 Megan Harry and their
son Archie went on a 10-day tour of
Africa
there Harry told ITV he and his brother
were on different paths but will always
be there for each other
Megan also said the year since marrying
Harry had been hard
in January 2020 Harry and Megan
announced they were stepping back from
their Royal roles and they wanted to
become financially independent they also
said they would split their time between
the UK and the US
despite saying they would fully support
the queen Buckingham Palace wasn't
informed about the statement prior to
its release
Harry who had been in talks with Charles
and Camilla said his hands were tied the
decision that I have made for my wife
and I to step back is not one I made
lightly there really was no other option
a joint statement was released on behalf
of the brothers following reports
William had bullied Harry out of the
family
in March 2020 Harry and Megan who were
living in La returned to the UK for
their final engagements as senior Royals
they attended the Commonwealth day
service alongside Prince William and
Kate relations now noticeably Frosty
by February 2021 Buckingham Palace
announced that Harry and Megan would not
be returning as working Royals Harry was
stripped of his military appointments
and Royal patronages Megan and Harry
released a counter-statement saying they
remained committed to their Duty and
service to the UK
in March 2021 the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex gave a tell-all interview with
Oprah Winfrey which aired in the U.S and
the UK in it Harry said Charles had
stopped taking his calls and Megan
denied she'd made Kate cry over
bridesmaid's dresses the reverse
happened she said but most damaging of
all the couple claimed a member of the
royal household had raised concerns
about the color of Archie's skin and can
you just let me know is that the royal
family a racist family sir
not
[Music]
a month later Prince Harry went to his
grandfather's funeral Megan stayed in
California
and in September 2022 Prince Harry and
Megan attended the funeral of the late
Queen King Charles and his two sons
reunited to walk behind her coffin
but when William and Kate flew to the
U.S to visit Boston in December William
didn't see his brother
I just really wanted the music to be fun
that same month Harry and Megan's
Netflix docu-series is released in it
Harry speaks in detail about the
breakdown of the relationship between
him and William he says William screamed
and shouted at him at a summit meeting
hell to discuss the couple's decision to
step back as working Royals
Prince Harry published his Memoir spare
on January the 10th he claims he and his
brother begged their father not to marry
Camilla
he also says he was physically attacked
by Prince William during a row in 2019
over Megan he says the Prince of Wales
grabbed him by the collar ripping his
necklace before throwing him to the
ground
after much speculation Prince Harry's
confirmed that he will attend the king's
coronation next month on April the 12th
just weeks before King Charles's
coronation Buckingham Palace confirmed
Harry would be attending Megan though
would stay in California with their
children Archie and lillibet the Duke of
Sussex says like his mother he always
felt different to the rest of the family
but after airing his grievances about
the Royals so publicly any hopes of
restoring relations seem a long way off
okay